#HASHTAGWARS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THE NUMBER ONE MOVIE IN AMERICA
THIS WEEKEND WAS "DIVERGENT",
BASED ON A POPULAR
YOUNG ADULT NOVEL.
SO IT LOOKS LIKE THE MOVIE
DIDN'T RUIN THIS BELOVED BOOK,
BUT TONIGHT'S HASHTAG WILL
BECAUSE IT IS
#RUINACHILDRENSBOOK.
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE "HARRY POTTER
AND THE CRIPPLING DEBT" OR
"CHARLOTTE'S WEBBED FEET" OR
"HORTON HEARS HIS CANCER
DIAGNOSIS."
(LAUGHTER)
ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK STARTING NOW.
HANNIBAL.
>> OH, THE PLACES YOU'LL GO
WHEN YOU NEED TO SCORE COCAINE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS, YES, OF
COURSE.
ELIZA.
>> THE LION, THE WITCH AND THE
WAR CRIMES.
>> Chris: POINTS.
KAMAU.
>> GOOD NIGHT (BLEEP).
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS!
ELIZA.
>> AMELIA PEDOPHILIA.
>> Chris: POINTS!
YES, HANNIBAL.
>> THE HARDY BOYS BANG JUDY
BLUME?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: WAIT.
THE HARDY BOYS STEPPED OUT OF A
BOOK AND BANG A CHILDREN'S
AUTHOR?
>> YEAH, MAN.
>> Chris: AS SHE'S TRYING TO
WRITE, "ARE YOU THERE GOD, IT'S
ME, MARGARET."
>> CROSS PROMOTION, MAN.
>> Chris: POINTS, YEAH, POINTS.
ELIZA.
>> RUMPLE FORESKIN.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: MOST OF EUROPE.
POINTS.
ONE MORE, KAMAU.
>> THE CAT IN THE HAT (BLEEP) ON
MY BACK.
(LAUGHTER)
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
TOO SOON?